bonsoir le 7-8 l'acte une nouvelle
édition et les 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur télé film nous
allons revenir dans un instant sur
l'actualité de ce 25 février en
compagnie du délégué régional du clip
une structure qui intervient en prison
auprès des détenus afin de leur offrir
la possibilité de se réinsérer via
l'outil informatique ce sera dans
quelques instants auparavant une photo
celle d'un tableau datant de l'époque de
napoléon 1er volet au château de
versailles
ce portrait du comte regnault de saint
jean d'angély réalisé par le baron
gérard a été dérobé dans une réserve une
plante a été déposée hier soir mais
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
sa disparition pourrait remonter à plus
de quatre ans le préjudice est estimé à
cent mille euros
le salon de l'agriculture porte de
versailles à paris et qui se poursuit
jusqu'au 2 mars près de sept cent mille
visiteurs attendus une vitrine unique
pour les exposants notamment à les
yvelinois claire cambier était présente
elle nous explique le travail du cervia
paris ile de france un organisme qui
assure la promotion des produits et des
savoir faire locaux
le célèbre salon de l'agriculture a
ouvert ses portes samedi dernier
parmi les stands des vaches des moutons
et autres animaux de la ferme et bien
entendu un pavillon dédié aux
productions culinaires régionales
cette année encore de nombreux yvelinois
ont rejoint le stand ile de france et
parmi eux thierry ce qu'ils proposent
des macarons à base de produits locaux
en plateforme de grignon pour le beurre
des choses comme ça tout ce qui est
macarons fruité on essaye de on a un
producteur de fruits aux à lui et pour
tout ce qui est fruits rouges
alors quand on peut faire local autant
que faire se peut
différé colas et c'est là la priorité on
va dire le consommer local une priorité
pour l'ensemble des exposants ici des
yaourts de grignon la libye celui
fabriqué à crêpières ou encore de la
soupe de la ferme de gally
tous sont d'ailleurs membres du cervia
un organisme de la région les de france
qui promeut le territoire et notamment
ses productions agricoles avec le cervia
tu es notre comité de promotion des
produits
on encourage on donne des moyens en
fonctionnement en investissement et le
résultat c'est que chaque année on a
davantage de stands ici et que on est
devenu un des plus grands stands du
salon
alors qu'on est là à jour bailleul et
c'est non sans surprise que des
visiteurs ont découvert des produits
made in ile-de-france comme cet
aveyronnais venu à paris pour découvrir
le salon surprenant c'est bien chicorée
qu'ils fassent aussi leur
leurs produits qu'ils essayent de
reconnaître leur région beaucoup des
exposants évinois n'aurait pas pu venir
au salon sans ce stand les places de
chacun sont financés à 50% par le cervia
participe au salon de l'agriculture
c'est à un vrai engagement en termes de
budget communication et
voilà c'est la crise pour tout le monde
donc les budgets communication c'est
forcément a généralement la première
chose sur la guerre va avoir tendance à
rogner est en tout ce sont près de 600
produits qui sont issus de l'agriculture
locale pour les retrouver en dehors du
salon de servier a annoncé en 2011 la
marque saveurs paris de pons et le salon
de l'agriculture ce sera aussi le
prochain thème du numéro de fil échos de
ce jeudi dès 18h30 en direct pour la
première diffusion le tramway t6
châtillon viroflay actuellement en phase
d'essais dynamiques sont actuellement à
tester les systèmes de sécurité les
systèmes embarqués les systèmes en
station pour les voyageurs également
jusqu'au mois d'avril les essais
dynamiques se déroule sur les premiers
neuf kilomètres de ce qui deviendra à
terme le plus long tramway de france
nous avions bien sûr déjà eu l'occasion
de vous le faire découvrir
lors d'un précédent numéro à déquilibre
sur notre antenne le magazine de
l'environnement prochaine étape pour ce
tramway la formation des conducteurs
durant les prochaines semaines en tout
cas la ratp appellent des riverains à
faire preuve de vigilance avec les
changements de circulation et qui sont
engendrés et bien évidemment à respecter
les règles de circulation donc il est
bientôt l'heure de passer à table si
vous nous suivez en direct en ce 25
février nous allons parler à présent de
restauration dans ce journal direction
montigny le bretonneux où le chef est de
l'établissement la fontaine vient de
recevoir la distinction de maître
restaurateur
olivier maniscalco jonathan vilma
deuxième label de qualité pour le
restaurant la fontaine à montigny en
mars 2013 l'établissement avait déjà
reçu le titre de collège culinaire de
france reconnaissance par des
professionnels d'une cuisine de qualité
cette fois début février c'est le label
maître restaurateur qui est inauguré ce
dernier décernée par l'état récompense
également la qualité des produits
proposés par l'établissement
le restaurant spécialisé dans le poisson
et autres produits de la mer est
aujourd'hui le seul sur saint quentin en
yvelines à détenir ces deux sésames
c'est une fierté et une récompense mais
je regrette quand même qu'on soit pas un
peu plus nombreux
c'est un moyen aussi de lutter contre on
va dire la malbouffe n'ayons pas peur
des mots
la cuisine industrielle qu'on voit un
petit peu partout dans les médias il ya
des débats des émissions et c'est donc
là il ya de la belle pour rassurer le
consommateur marée de rungis marché de
versailles pisciculture bio en normandie
la traçabilité est un critère important
pour le chef josé moreau et même si les
deux labels apporte une bonne publicité
à l'établissement
son patron regrette d'être seul gage de
cette qualité dans l'agglomération pour
lui avec d'autres restaurateurs
labellisé à saint quentin les clients
n'irai pas autant voir ailleurs sur la
ville nouvelle par exemple on serait un
peu plus nombreux dans ce cas de figure
ça nous permettrait de fixer la
clientèle sur la ville nouvelle et
d'avoir un peu moins de suite vers
versailles vers paris vers la vallée de
chevreuse voilà donc évidemment je suis
fier qu'on soit dans cette situation
mais j'appelle mes collègues à venir
avec nous des collègues restaurateurs
souvent mal informés sur ce type de
label
pourtant le titre de maître restaurateur
peut permettre un crédit d'impôt allant
jusqu'à quinze mille euros dans les
yvelines seuls 27 établissements sur
1000 restaurants l'ont obtenu l'invité
de cette édition à présent c est
christian bonsoir je vous êtes le
délégué régional du clip le club
informatique pénitentiaire association
loi 1901 qui se fixe comme objectif de
former et des détenus dans les prisons
vous recherchez aujourd'hui des
bénévoles pour vous aider on va être
même repréciser pour commencer vos
objectifs l'histoire du clip remonte à
deux étudiants qui fondent cette
association les cours débutent
rapidement à bois d'arcy et aujourd'hui
cela concerne 2000 détenus à travers 40
établissements pénitentiaires en france
53 même 53 pays l'établissement france
et 40 et 13 en ile de france a été lancé
mis en place et c'est juste l'initiative
comme ça de deux étudiants exactement
l'initiative de deux étudiants qui sans
doute s'intéresse à l'informatique et y
venaient du génépi le génépi c'est une
association d'étudiants qui intervient
dans l'établissement pénitentiaire est
né rue l'idée que l'informatique
pourrait être un moyen de d'aider les
détenus à préparer leur retour à la vie
civile et
sur un sirh et donc dans département des
yvelines vous intervenez à la maison
centrale de poissy dans les maisons
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy également et puis
la prison pour femmes à à versailles
quels sont les résultats que vous
obtenez déjà ça permet de donner des
projets un avenir de se projeter un
petit peu à ces détenus
oui alors bon les motivations des
détenus il est difficile et pas toujours
évident de les déterminer
bien sûr certains viennent pour passer
le temps aussi pour rencontrer des des
personnes avec qui peuvent avoir un
contact différent de ce qu'ils peuvent
avoir
au jour le jour dans les établissements
nous essayons nous pour notre part de
leur apporter des compétences et nous
les encourageons vivement à aller
jusqu'au moment où on peut leur faire
passer un diplôme
nous avons une convention avec l'afpa
l'association professeur de formation
des adultes qui délivrent des diplômes
des certificats d'aptitude au traitement
de texte tableur niveau 1 niveau 2 est
aussi en association avec l'éducation
nationale nous pouvons préparer les
détenus au b2i le brevet informatique et
internet qui donne une culture générale
très large sur les technologies de
l'information d'aujourd'hui
ça les aide à se réinsérer ensuite il
faut qu'il sorte de prison à trouver
plus facilement un travail est ce que
vous avez un suivi un peu alors non nous
n'avons pas de service après vente
nous on a déjà le fait de pouvoir
montrer à une personne qui est souvent
décrochage scolaire qui a quitté l'école
prématurément qu'il est capable
d'apprendre qu'il est capable de se
concentrer de progresser et nous
l'espérons est le plus souvent d'obtenir
un diplôme c'est déjà très valorisant
pour lui ensuite bas si à une personne
des ex-détenus se présentent sur le
marché du travail avec un certificat pas
traitement de texte tableur pour un
employeur c'est quelque chose qui compte
cela montre qu' il a une maîtrise d'un
outil informatique ce qui est absolument
indispensable dans la vie d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi ce avec la formation
navigation sur internet toutes ces
choses là bien sûr avec des simulateurs
puis ce que j'imaginais que l'intérieur
des prisons il n'a pas de possibilité
aujourd'hui d'avoir accès à l'internet
mais avec une des outils de simulation
on leur apprend à utiliser naviguer sur
internet voir ce qu'il ya comme services
disponibles sur internet et comment
s'organiser pour prendre ces
informations elle est stockée dans
l'ordinateur et les mettre en forme
éventuellement dans des dossiers ou des
rapports pourquoi l'informatique
pourquoi cet outil informatique parce
que tout passe par l'informatique
aujourd'hui d'écouter c'est l'histoire
du clip
donc pourquoi l'informatique il ya
beaucoup d'autres activités qui sont
proposées aux détenus en prison beaucoup
d'activités
vous avez le culte bien entendu les
différents cultes musulmans et chrétiens
juifs et autres vous avez la gymnastique
le sport vous avez l'éducation nationale
bien sûr il ya un référent local
d'établissement de l'éducation nationale
dans chaque établissement qui propose
des cours et qui forment le détenu qui
sont volontaires il ya aussi la poterie
le dessin et toutes ses activités
l'informatique est une activité commune
hôte n'avait pas une formation
proprement dit et ce qui nous diffère de
l'éducation nationale puisque des
questions nationales fait une formation
avec des professeurs nous nous apportons
des compétences et nous le faisons à
l'aide de bénévoles
mais les vols qui dont les motivations
sont souvent de découvrir le milieu
pénitentiaire est ce que nous demandons
aux bénévoles
c'est de maîtriser à minima ces outils
informatiques parce que bien sûr quand
on les enseignes faut pouvoir répondre
aux questions mais vous les aidez
exactement et interviennent alors là je
dis aux bénévoles potentiels qui nous
regardent qu'eux il ne faut pas avoir
d'appréhension par rapport à la maîtrise
de l'outil informatique je dirais
maîtrisé même modestement les outils
informatiques être capable de lancer un
programme de faire un peu de traitements
thèse connaît tous word et excel ou un
tableur openoffice ou calq gouv writer
ça suffit ensuite nous disposions de
support de court qui permettent à ses
formateurs de se former avec le support
de court et c'est une chose qui est
intéressante au delà de l'apport humain
que représente le fait d'intervenir face
à des détenus d'abord la relation qui
peut s'établir évidemment au cours de
deux heures et demie ses limites et 2h30
même chaque semaine plusieurs fois deux
heures et demie c'est limité mais
c'était une expérience enrichissante
par ailleurs il ya
1une un apport le fait de former des
gens c'est quelque chose que tout le
monde n'a pas fait dans sa vie donc une
expérience de la pédagogie et en même
temps une expérience technique sur les
outils puisque moi-même qui utilisent
depuis des années les outils
informatiques j'ai appris énormément de
choses dans les supports de cours et je
faisais des choses de la manière qu'ils
étaient pas forcément la plus efficace
et ses enseignements m'a permis de
progresser et n'oublions étoilé
véritablement important parce que c'est
le bénévole qui va motiver ensuite le
détenu et il va se passer quelque chose
un lien qui va se vendre éducatif
exactement le alors même si nous évitons
toute relation personnelle ça ça fait
partie de notre aux règles de
fonctionnement
il est pas loin d souhaitable c'est même
proscrit que chaque bénévole qu'un
bénévole donne ses coordonnées
personnelles un détenu ni n'empêche que
d'homme à homme de ma femme ou de femme
à hommes puisque nous avons des femmes
dans l'établissement dormait des hommes
dans l'établissement femme il ya une
relation
j'irai de personnel qui s'établit et le
fait que en général nos bénévoles soit
des gens qui ont un bon bagage culturel
et une bonne expérience constitue pour
notre public
quelque chose d'important parce que ils
ont en contact avec une personne qui
peut apporter autre chose que à
l'apprentissage de l'outil informatique
aujourd'hui alors oui aujourd'hui nous
en manquons puisque bon notre population
et étant essentiellement formée de
retraités parce que nos interventions
sont le plus souvent entre 8 heures et
demie le lundi matin et 17 heures le
vendredi soir ça limite un petit peu la
possibilité de faire intégrer des actifs
mais si vous êtes actif et si vous êtes
intéressé par le clip nous trouverons un
moyen de vous employez donc pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur en ile de
france nous étions 56 il y avait cinq
ans six bénévoles
il y a deux ans nous ya un + 43 et en
face de ça il ya une demande très très
important des établissements
pénitentiaires des détenus mais des
directeurs d'établissements
réau par exemple c'est une grosse maison
d'arrêt il ya aujourd'hui plus
d'activités clip alors qu'on pourrait
avoir dix bénévoles du clip relancer ses
activités on va afficher une nouvelle
fois à l'écran les coordonnées pour
prendre contact avec le clip et les
christian baume notamment merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau nous parler de ses
activités merci avait une dernière
information à présent elle concerne
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'ancienne
présidente sylvie faucheux qui sort de
son silence ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur court à des comptes
l'accablent pour ses choix lorsqu'elle
dirigeait l'établissement choix qui
aurait entraîné la crise financière
actuelle et dans les colonnes du
parisien elle explique que durant ses
dix ans de présidence l'université n'a
jamais connu de difficultés qu'à son
départ les ressources propres était de
plus de 17 millions d'euros selon elle
selon elle la situation s'explique par
l'augmentation du nombre d'élèves
l'arrêt des recherches de ressources
extérieures et le coût de la maintenance
des partenariats public-privé et depuis
le 14 février le rectorat a repris la
main sur les comptes de cette université
de versailles saint quentin il doit
établir un budget équilibré avant le 1er
mars
l'aktu revient demain à 18 heures
toujours en direct sur tv films nous
parlerons notamment et du scrutin des
européennes catherine mulato qui s'est
rendu à bruxelles à la rencontre des
députés pour évoquer l'autre grand
rendez vous électoral de cette année à
2014 excellente soirée sur téléphiles